[Music]
don't worry about me just keep on doing
what you're doing practical magic cgi
magic chaos magic these series saw them
all we're taking an insider look at just
how all the marvel magic came to be from
the practical effects of wand division
to a modified loki variant costume to
elena's bathroom blip to bucky's arm
we're covering it all my favorite box
fake bite yeah it makes me stand
properly and it makes me kind of want to
do this too number one
luckily the production crew had his back
right off the bat the loki series
dropped quite the stunt literally
dropping into the time variance
authority was courtesy of a real
trapdoor and wires while it was
controlled hiddleston really did let the
stunt team take the reins as they helped
him fall onto his mark that's one way to
get around
number two
when a loki has a baby marvel finds a
solution sophia dimartino was pregnant
when she first auditioned for the series
and by the time she was filming her
little one was by her side and needed to
nurse pretty frequently those marvel
superhero suits are notorious for being
tricky to get in and out of but not when
there's a costume designer like
christine wada around to add hidden
zippers this made slipping out of the
suit enough to nurse a way easier
process the marvel fan is as tight-knit
as it gets
number three
weapons at the ready loki is here and he
ain't holding back tom hiddleston
himself was responsible for a ton of his
own fights keeping the speedy action
like a pro on set not to mention the
other loki who seems to be one of the
best fighting partners a person could
ask for the training was long and
intense but so worth it hiddleston is
extremely skilled with his hand-to-hand
combat not missing a beat in major
sequences
number four
are we seeing double the usual doubles
the masters of secret keeping wanted to
keep sylvie's identity hidden so they
had male and female stunt doubles
kicking it on set as one of the tactics
to keep fans guessing at what loki
variant we'd be getting such a gift of a
character i get to just be this absolute
badass who's really angry the second
episode sees variant sylvie appearing in
the shadows and behind the scenes both
men and women made appearances to keep
us on our toes a tiny detail but it's
what makes us love this show even more
number five
bust out those dancing shoes marvel's
about to groove the first time i heard
about the concept i thought it was
brilliant the vintage vibes were strong
off the top of wandavision and while it
started shooting in 2019 the set was
brimming with technologies from the 50s
and 60s all the magic cooking was
courtesy of old-fashioned filming
techniques including hooking all those
kitchen supplies up to wires the
finishing touches took advantage of the
cgi tech we have now to remove all those
wires digitally for the most part what
we see surrounding wanda is the real
deal and the live studio audience can
attest to that
number six
let's take a trip to the town square
westview has seen a whole lot of action
particularly in the town square if you
know you know now the gazebo was home to
many an old timey performance and
afternoon hangout no matter the decade
the structure was there except for the
fact that it wasn't always real real as
it looked and felt masterful cgi brought
it to life while the actors hung out
with their old pal the blue screen
number seven
it was agatha all along so hard so
worth it but not without some wires and
heavy duty fans katherine han really
reveled in the experience the first time
i was like lifted up on those wires i
really almost burst into tears the
village it took to bring the show to
life was necessary their fights aren't
quite the same without all those effects
number eight
if wanda doesn't want you in the hex you
don't stay in the hex and i want you
to leave monica rambo soldiered through
the series with her going in and out of
the hex and on occasion geraldine had a
one-way ticket for the wanda express
heading straight out of west view tayana
paris fortunately didn't have to take
the rough ride a 3d model was designed
based on the actress and when the
effects team went to work they put all
the layers together and those special
blast effects that really make this
sequence
number nine
we love to see it paul bettany had quite
a lot of work to do for his human to
android transitions you're the new clown
yeah at least you're already in makeup
he had to film the exact same scene
twice in the most exact way possible
while wearing both different looks cue
the special effects team to blend the
shots so vision could morph before our
eyes while adding a dash of pizzazz
whether it was the bewitched style
twinkles or the tron vibe light ray even
when he was in bits it was all a
fabrication with betany as a model of
course while the actor did endure the
hours-long process to prep the final
cuts are all cg and no betany at least
not visually
number 10
black and white on screen regular color
on set not this time filming all of
these episodes did happen in color only
rendering the footage to black and white
and post but not everything would
translate so well with this so when we
translated red vision into black and
white he didn't really look like vision
so he got suited up as a kind of
periwinkle vision in the early episodes
even when he is an android he looks a
bit more human so how does he suddenly
look more robotic later on the secret is
in the eyelashes the fourth episode
onwards sees a vision with digitally
removed eyelashes and wow is it ever
effective number eleven
who needs a cape when you've got cgi
okay we're sure paul benny would have
dug actually wearing a cape on set but
the thing is capes can have a knack for
getting in the way
that cape is a full cgi creation and is
masterfully edited to move in different
ways chill vibes casual cape motion a
scene feeling tense high stakes that cg
cape will take center stage whipping
about in the wind
number 12.
one blip bathroom coming right up the
room elena gets blipped in was literally
built from the ground up by the team
inside a mansion they needed to build
the set so it could work for them to get
the whole sequence and it got a full
redecorating makeover instead of going
with cgi the team wanted to keep the
show as grounded in reality as they
could sometimes the human way is the
best way the transitions from moment to
moment well in this case the cgi was
definitely the better way
number 13
clear your schedule this blip is going
to take a few days yes literally a few
days but all kind of the same on the
first day of work the camera crew needed
to pay extra special close attention to
what they did and how they did it
because they'd need to start over from
the beginning all over again capturing
everything the exact same way for
another take on their first day the
final moment captured was planned to a t
enter the bathroom turn on the tap tilt
camera this kind of precision was
extremely tough to nail but is it any
surprise the marvel team pulled it off
number 14.
the human actors were great but we've
got to talk about the dog marvel fans
everywhere got a treat when we saw
lucky's role join the hawkeye series
casting was open and they wound up going
with the delightful lady dog jolt cg is
easier than actually working with
animals on set in most cases but not in
this one jolt was a dream to work with
for the cast and crew members and
performed better than the team
anticipated the only bit of cg that was
used was to hide one of jolt's eyes oh
and for all those wondering yes lucky
the pizza dog does in fact like pizza
number 15.
the falcon wasn't messing around that
big old montage yeah it was chock full
of intense rigs to capture all the
action when he was running the film crew
hopped on a cart racing through the
woods when the shield took center stage
the team realized just how brutal that
could be on the trees it didn't really
feel right to harm mother nature so out
came the mats to keep those trees
protected they made the final cut
instead of being cg'ed out because well
let's be real it would be kind of weird
to have captain america destroying a
bunch of harmless trees
number 16
squirrel suits say no more before they
even started filming a whole lot of
people jumped out of a plane with
cameras rigged up to their bodies so the
falcon and the winter soldier team could
see just what it would look like to
plummet and glide through the air what i
really wanted to do for the big action
sequences was as much as possible make
things feel like they're grounded in
reality this aerial battle was unlike
any sequence marvel had done before and
it's no surprise that it was super
tricky to pull off but after a lot of
tests planning and squirrel suits they
managed to capture the action stunningly
in this thrill-filled battle
number 17
is it a set is it a bouncy castle
sometimes it could be hard to tell
anthony mackie and sebastian stan were
doing their own stunts but in this case
well maybe it's not so much of a stunt
as it is sort of falling onto a giant
mat with the risk level so low the fun
level was high
number 18.
why do you get out on parked trucks when
you can use moving trucks way to amp it
up falcon and the winter soldier the
truck tops the actors performed on were
actually much smaller than the ones we
see on screen and well not so mobile the
stunt team shot their choreo at a higher
level with cg tying it all together so
seamlessly that the actors actually had
a hard time telling when it was them or
their stunt doubles in the show
number 19.
so anyone know where to get a vibranium
arm nope but the marvel production team
can do you one better practical and
digital effects as soon as talk of the
arm starts we start knowing that that's
that's probably going to be a visual
effect shot the whole arm falling off
[ __ ] yeah you can bet cg was needed to
hide stan's actual arm and then
sebastian was a good sport about having
his arm tucked behind his back when the
arm was attached to his body stan was
often sporting a special rubber arm
sleeve to wear that looked so on point
that the vfx team had a nearly perfect
reference about 30 to 40 percent of that
arm actually makes the cut we try to do
as much practically as possible
number 20
the wakandans know how to protect
themselves the arm might be on bucky
barnes but it's still got a bit of
wakandan in it there was a whole lot of
discussion on how to make sure that the
fail-safe the wakandan setup was
represented somehow visually should
there be a little purple wakandan energy
signature or a little light to just help
the audience figure out what's going on
slowing it down we can see a tiny surge
of light and while it's easy to miss we
love to see this kind of tiny detail
from the almost missable details to the
major builds and complex practical
effects he used the marvel team really
knew how to take advantage of the best
of the best to bring these series to
life making a show at the marvel movie
scale meant they pulled out all the
stops creating some of our favorite tv
show magic
you